comercios desaparecidos la mayoría de
las casas en escombros e iglesias vacías
santos 3 se convirtió en una de las
comunidades fantasma de brasil por los
impactos de las excavaciones de minas de
oro este barrio al noroeste de brasilia
está a unos 200 metros de será grande un
gigantesco complejo minero de la
sudafricana anglogold ashanti según las
denuncias presentadas por los locales
muchas personas desarrollan problemas
pulmonares y contaminación acústica por
las explosiones de rocas sus viviendas
corren peligro también
de la mina a cielo abierto está muy
cerca entra polvo hay varios otros
factores había quejas de los vecinos de
allí sobre el temblor de las casas la
vibración de las casas como si fuera un
terremoto sus tramos
la comunidad de santos rey se asentó en
1995 nueve años después de que empezaron
las operaciones de cerra grande que
supone el motor económico de la región
donde genera unos 2.000 empleos directos
pero después de 27 años de existencia
santo rey se presta a morir
quizás hoy si miras alrededor de crisis
no ves un trabajo hecho por la empresa
vemos que si terminara hoy un crisis
pues minero a que se abra el crisis hoy
vemos que no hay nada razón que extravió
por el switch santa race no es la única
comunidad fantasma en brasil en maceió
capital del estado de alagoas 5 barrios
residenciales donde viven unas 60.000
personas fueron sentenciadas al mismo
destino en 2019 270 personas de
brumadinho murieron tras la ruptura de
una presa de residuos químicos que
provocó un mar de lodo que sepultó
viviendas aledañas y parte de las
instalaciones de la propia empresa